28 janvier 2020 la réforme des retraites
arrive à l'assemblée
la droite veut marquer les esprits elle
sort les écharpes tricolores pour
dénoncer une réforme mal préparée
un texte incomplet qu'il faut examiner
dans un calendrier trop serré
c'est votre amateurisme qui court du
rail on le sait au 49 3 et au déni de
démocratie
un déni de démocratie c'est aussi ce que
dénonce la gauche
un mois plus tard
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre edouard philippe sort une arme
fatale
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 j'ai décidé
d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite
comment en est on arrivé là
on est lundi il est 9h15 il reste 33
1791 amendements tous les moyens ont été
utilisés pour ralentir les débats on va
leur pourrir la vie parce qu'ils veulent
courir des retraites je redemande mesure
où ces mentions de séance et je
redemande un scrutin public sur la
suspension de séance
dit en français que vous assumez votre
obstruction la bataille s'est joué sur
quelques mots quelques dates
nous vous proposons à travers de cette
belle série d'amendements de repousser à
plus tard
l'entrée en vigueur de votre réforme
2057 au lieu de 2022 2058 2055 au kazoo
puisque à 2082 et même au delà
une guerre des nerfs pour la majorité
vous imposez le monologue et le
monologue c'est simplement l'antichambre
des dictatures
quelle image donne aux loups de trappes
dans cette bataille pour remporter la
mise
et ben ya eu des coups de bluff des
coups bas des imprévus aussi chacun à
jouer ses atouts avec un seul objectif
faire craquer l'adversaire
[Musique]
17h01 vendredi soir à l'assemblée
à l'heure où tout le monde part en week
end les bureaux de la france insoumise
sont dans une étrange effervescence les
textes c'est le deuxième c'est la loi
ordinaire
ok pour créer un amendement et à une
économie si je clique dessus
là tu marques présentées par autant il a
autant qui marquent et là c'est parfait
je descends descends ses collaborateurs
déposent des amendements par milliers
avant l'examen en commission il ne
s'agit pas d'améliorer le texte mais de
le supprimer
alinéa par alinéa une stratégie assumée
donc tu fais cette année serait supprimé
ok et là tu fais pas déposer tu fait
enregistrer dupliquer pour faire du
volume
chaque amendement est dupliquée 17 fois
au nom des dix sept députés du groupe
de quoi mettre en surchauffe le logiciel
de l'assemblée
ouais ça rame un petit peu parce que ça
fait un peu buggé la machine mais ça
marche c'est clair a fait dévier la
matrice et ils vont être contents les
services informatiques
je pense que chaque amendement donnera
droit à deux minutes de temps de parole
un jackpot de paroles que vous gagnez
bec on espère pouvoir à voir et surtout
du temps de réponse pour que le
gouvernement réponde un peu franchement
et honnêtement aux questions donc voilà
on dispose de ce moyen là eh bien on va
l'utiliser
la bataille peut commencer la première
manche va se jouer ici en commission
spéciale
elle va examiner le texte pendant neuf
jours avec pas moins de six rapporteur
comme une répétition générale avant
l'hémicycle face à la majorité
un petit groupe de députés communistes
socialistes et un sumyk qui partagent la
même table la discussion promet d'être
longue
nous débutons donc aujourd'hui l'examen
des 21 1661 amendements déposés sur le
projet de loi instituant un système
universel l'opération de la france
insoumise n'était donc pas du bluff
plus de 21 mille amendements 19 1700
rien que pour le groupe de jean luc
mélenchon les députés insoumis prennent
la main il ne la lâcheront plus donc
l'amendement 796 madame autun oui c'est
un amendement de suppression nous
proposons de supprimer l'article
intégralement monsieur bernalicis mais
dès qu'il s'agit de supprimer cette
année à 8 suit le 3423 madame aux tables
oui nous continuons donc notre travail
pour dépecer ce texte
au troisième jour on en est toujours à
l'article premier d'un texte qui en
compte 64 les esprits s'échauffent
je suis navré de voir que nous sommes
davantage dans un vaudeville ce soir que
dans un véritable débat parlementaire
quelle conception de la démocratie
avez-vous bon cher collègue s'il vous
plaît de grâce remballez définitivement
vos leçons de démocratie
merci tout le monde se calme après neuf
jours de débats moins d'un tiers des
amendements ont été examinées la
présidente de la commission jette les
pompes alors je prends à que notre
commission n'est pas en mesure d'achever
la discussion des articles du projet de
loi ordinaire
merci
les travaux s'arrêtent sans être arrivé
à la fin du texte les députés ont donc
siéger pour rien ils repartiront de zéro
dans l'hémicycle c'est une première
c'est du foutage de gueule c'est l'unité
l'inutilité totale
une commission spéciale on a passé
beaucoup de temps beaucoup d'énergie
beaucoup d'argent public également pour
au final dire circulez ya rien à voir
tout ce qu'on aura débattu en commission
spéciale ne sert à rien puisque en fait
on va revenir avec le texte initial du
gouvernement on le savait les insoumis
eux revendiquent une première victoire
et la gauche se tourne déjà vers la
bataille suivante celle de l'hémicycle
on va faire mieux on va évidemment
entrer dans tous les détails
aucun ne leur sera épargné ça va donc
prendre des semaines et des semaines et
des semaines va additionner nos
arguments additionner nos forces on va
leur pourrir la vie parce qu'ils veulent
pourrir les retraites et on va le faire
par tous moyens
c'est sur ces bons que va se jouer l'une
des réformes majeures du quinquennat
deux semaines sont prévues une troisième
est possible pas au delà a décidé le
gouvernement la majorité n'a pas pu
amendé le texte en commission
elle entend se rattraper dans
l'hémicycle que de reconnaître parmi les
députés en marche
catherine fabre et monique limon elles
ont sillonné la france pendant un an
pour défendre cette réforme et elles se
disent prêtes à faire face à
l'obstruction
il n'est pas question comme ça a pu être
dit de se taire tout le temps mais de
parler au bon moment et pour dire les
choses de fond cantonné dans ces
conditions là on est obligé de choisir
d'être court et percutant
donc c'est ce qu'on essaiera de faire
c'est pas dur de rester calme face à des
écoutes et c'est une vraie épreuve
c'est une vraie preuve de zénitude mais
justement on en train de progresser là
c'est pas mal
restez zen ne pas céder aux provocations
ce sera tout l'enjeu de la nouvelle
partie qui commence
et dans cette seconde manche les
insoumis ne sont plus seuls ils vont
pouvoir compter sur le soutien des
communistes
c'est le jour j à l'assemblée dans moins
d'une heure commence le débat sur la
réforme des retraites micros tendus
caméra au poing ont filmé on écoute on
enregistre
et voilà qu'un des acteurs du débat se
présente face aux journalistes
sourire en coin jean luc mélenchon est
impatient d'en découdre
le monde voit les gens chez moi
aujourd'hui c'est une méthode
d'obstruction qui commence à lasser nuit
alors cette une très grande bataille
parlementaire qui commence et rien ne me
fait peur rien ne nous arrêtera
ni maintenant ni jamais c'est une
déclaration de guerre
la majorité s'y attendait face à nous
nous avons des oppositions qui ont
décidé d'hystériser ce débat de le
bloquer d'empêcher qu'ils aient lieu
nous sommes parfaitement prêts à
accepter d enrichissement de ce texte
mais en aucun cas nous nous laisseront
entraîner dans une spirale qui est
dangereuse pour notre institution
l'assemblée nationale et aussi pour
notre démocratie
un groupe de députés fait alors son
entrée salle des quatre colonnes tee
shirt blanc lettres rouges
chacun prend place il faut se mettre
dans le bon ordre pour former un mot
référendum
nous avons décidé de proposer une motion
référendaire
le peuple doit avoir la parole c'est
d'ailleurs un des fondements de la vème
république
nous allons demander donc un référendum
dans votre corps lieu ce soir référendum
les communistes ont passé la semaine à
recueillir 60 signatures
mais si un seul signataire manquent à
l'appel dans l'hémicycle tout tombe à
l'eau pas de vote pour réclamer ce
référendum
la carte est donc posée mais il faut
maintenant transformer l'essai
la séance va commencer
tous les signataires de la motion
référendaire doivent rejoindre
l'hémicycle
ok
c'est la motion référendaire oui
[Musique]
seulement il y a des retardataires on
les cherche
on s'inquiète l'opération risque de
capoter
clémentine autain
monsieur alexis corbière monsieur ugo
bernalicis richard ferrand égrène les
noms des 60 signataires jusqu'au verdict
final est enfin madame karamanli acte
est donnée de la présence effective en
séance des signataires de la motion
la parole est un monsieur fabien roussel
le débat va commencer de député en
profite alors pour s'éclipser les
menthes innocent a rejoint rassemblement
devant l'assemblée
aux côtés de la députée insoumise
la communiste est la faucille ont elles
ne portent pas d'écharpés tricolores
car ici on est plutôt booth bleus et
foulard rouge provenant de marquer le
début d'une sénatrice pour un con et
évidemment quand
la subvention pour voitures et marion
makuch révolution
à cet instant info emmanuel macron enisa
terre sous les yeux des deux députés
un acte symbolique qui fera polémique il
est l'heure de retourner dans
l'hémicycle pour voter la motion
référendaire
le scrutin est clos votants 230 majorité
116 pour 70 contre 160
la motion référendaire n'est pas adopté
sans surprise la motion est rejetée
mais la bataille ne fait que commencer
et donc ils vont se bouffer une bonne
pelletée d'amendements et chaque
amendement sera l'occasion de défendre
pied à pied notre projet provost à
toutes et tous d'autant tort j'en suis
sûr nous faisons une belle équipe
merci à toutes et tous et bravo la
séance est ouverte
la pelletée d'amendements la voici
il y en a quarante et un mille un record
pour cette législature la moitié vient
des insoumis et 13000 des communistes
en face le président de l'assemblée dans
un conte une carte qui permet de
supprimer des amendements par centaines
j'ai eu l'occasion en conférence des
présidents d'indiquer que cette règle
logique sera appliquée de manière
systématique
il en sera donc ainsi fait mais si si si
si si j'ai la règle puisque j'ai le
micro la règle a changé que tous les
collègues comprennent va pas changer ce
dont il s'agit permettez moi d'expliquer
des centaines de nos amendements vont
tomber avec une raie qui a changé en
cours de route monsieur le président
vous êtes en train de faire en sorte de
trouver une nouvelle arme pour museler
le parlement vous êtes en train
d'inventer à la faveur de cela une
nouvelle arme pour museler votre
position oui il y à ici un front
républicain qui dit que cet hémicycle et
cadenassé que cet hémicycle et martyrisé
et que cet hémicycle
nous voulons le libérer vous avez la
parole droite et gauche réunies
défendent leur droit d'amendement face à
richard ferrand vous vous bâillonner le
le débat regardez nous n'avons pas
déposé plus d'amendements que votre
majorité dont vous me dites qu'il s'agit
d'un bâillon alors qu'il restera minime
à 39 mille amendements à débattre croyez
- croyez moi vous aurez le temps
d'exprimer tous vos arguments simplement
richard ferrand veut accélérer les
débats l'opposition va user de toutes
ses cartes pour les faire traîner
au nom de l'article 100 je souhaite
faire un rappel au règlement
je vais demander une suspension de
séance et mon président un scrutin
public
la scène va se répéter plusieurs fois je
redemande suspension de séance et je
redemande un scrutin public sur la
suspension de séance la séance suspendue
pour cinq minutes les députés quittent
l'hémicycle à bout de nerfs car
l'épisode leur a déjà fait perdre une
journée
l'institution s'abîme aujourd'hui dans
la façon dont une partie de l'opposition
est en train de dévoyer le débat
parlementaire
le calme a décidément du mal à revenir
les députés vont jusqu'à se couper la
parole le chef donne en chef de clan
l'hystérie des marchés
valérie des marcheurs on ne veut pas
appliquer jamais fait ça les amis
d'enfance et ont vis-à-vis de tous ceux
qui nous regardent qui nous écoutent
aujourd'hui c'est incroyable on est en
train de discuter de 2,2 juridique alors
qu'on doit un débat aux français sous la
pression de richard ferrand fini par
céder il retire sa carte mais il
prévient ce matin à 9h30 6476 amendement
était encore en discussion à ce rythme
mais le 640 trois heures de séances
seront nécessaires pour terminer la
seule loi ordinaire soit 150 jours de
séance
commence alors une guerre d'usure
les séances se suivent et se ressemblent
la séance est ouverte
la majorité pointe du doigt
l'obstruction et ses amendements qui ne
changent souvent qu'un mot ou une
virgule
il reste 33 1791 amendements et on nous
propose de remplacer réduction par
diminution constante par continue et
préparez vous parce que dans quelques
minutes monsieur mélenchon va nous
proposer de remplacer assurant par
garantissant et madame obono de
remplacer assurance garantissant pas
rassurant dans ce spectacle chacun tient
son rôle celui des insoumis et de crier
au scandale mais que voulez-vous à la
fin une opposition qui ne s'opposent pas
qui ne demandent pas de supprimer les
articles de loin et qui ne votent pas
mais ça n'existe pas il ya quelque chose
de totalitaire dans ce rappel sans tête
au genre oui oui de totalitaire voulu
vous ne nous offrez aucune possibilité
d'entrer dans une discussion
car quoi que l'on dise vous est contée
vous criez donc buvait un bon coup
respire un bon coup d'air frais ça ira
mieux après
je dharréville c'est à qui craquera le
premier et à ce petit jeu les
communistes et des insoumis savent
parfaitement comment s'y prendre au
neuvième jour des débats
il dégaine une série de 700 amendements
pour changer année après année la date
d'application de la réforme
nous vous proposons avait à travers
cette cette belle série d'amendements de
repousser à plus tard
l'entrée en vigueur de votre réforme
nous demandons son application à partir
de 2050 7 au lieu de 2022 on porte
bonheur fait de reporter à 2058 nous
proposons donc de la repousser au delà
donc dans le premier amendement 2056
dans le suivant 2055 au kazoo oui on est
bien évidemment d'accord pour repousser
votre réforme des retraites jusqu'à 2082
et même au delà on est dans un tunnel de
700 amendements identiques qui vont
remplacer 2022 par 2060 de gaprée 2060
et à 2060 et cth cas de nul 2022 quand
est ce qu'on va pouvoir débattre on
trouve qu'il ya une imprécision dans
l'amendement proposé par nos camarades
communistes et on suggère de remplacer
au parent à tous les la majorité dénonce
l'absurdité du débat avant de quitter
l'hémicycle
nous reviendrons lorsque enfin nous
pourrons débattre
[Applaudissements]
bon voila mais nous on va continuer à
faire mon travail ici le pas deux merci
beaucoup monsieur d'arrivée mes chers
collègues la majorité finit par revenir
mais à ce jeu là certains s'épuise
après neuf jours de commissions et
autant d'hémicycle a réservé son
rapporteur le rapporteur nicolas
turquois ne cache pas sa fatigue
tout à l'heure vous l'avez pas vu je je
précise mais peut-être vu m'absenter un
quart d'heure ma femme et mes enfants
étaient en tribune ils sont venus me
voir je suis pas rentré depuis trois
semaines ils m'ont demandé s'ils sont
ils sont partis pour boire non non non
non non j'ai le droit en la faveur non
non j'ai le droit d'exprimer ses
sentiments mais sur un porteur poussé à
bout par cette série d'amendements
le rapporteur fini par craquer je vais
vous citer une citation qui m'est
revenue tout à l'heure je n'avais pas
prévu certains certains parmi vous
déclarez la république c'est moi
et bien moi je vous dit la république
c'est nous et vous vous êtes hors hard
[Musique]
l'opposition crie au scandale
le rapporteur aura beau s'excuser le mal
est fait à cet instant de la partie
l'issue est inéluctable il reste trop
d'amendements pour tenir le calendrier
un troisième joueur détient la solution
le premier ministre il n'a qu'une carte
en main l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
constitution
c'est un moyen de faire adopter un texte
sans vote
il lui suffirait de poser la carte pour
remporter la partie
la séance
cette carte est impopulaire
la majorité doit donc préparé l'opinion
à ce qui va se passer
elle va alors dénoncé la coupable à ses
yeux l'obstruction
arrêtez de nous faire perdre du temps
arrêter de poser des à mende demain le
rapporteur il a dit d'un septième sur
les mêmes choses assumer le fait que
vous voulez simplement faire capoter ce
projet il n'y a pas de problème
là-dessus mais le est dit est dit aux
français que vous assumez votre
obstruction arrêtez s'il vous plaît de
faire monter la sauce de faire monter la
sauce dans l'hémicycle nous sommes sur
un débat qui se déploie normalement et
vous avez là 49,3 dans toutes vos têtes
mais prenez l'air prenez l'air et on
continue le débat continuellement les
débats vont continuer normalement
pendant deux jours nous sommes un samedi
en fin de journée le secrétaire d'état
fait un signe au président de séance
monsieur le ministre je vous entends
prouve qu'on
monsieur mais ils se demandent une 6,60
séance de 10 minutes allaient de droit
les députés ont du mal à y croire
le conseil des ministres at il déjà
donné son feu vert aux 49 3 il y a bien
eu une réunion du gouvernement le matin
même mais c'était pour évoquer la crise
du coronavirus la séance et reprises la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre edouard philippe monte à la
tribune
il abat alors l'unique carte qu'il a
entre les mains
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 et après en
avoir obtenu l'autorisation du conseil
des ministres du 29 février
[Applaudissements]
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite
je vous remercie monsieur edouard
philippe avec ses airs de dandy qui
touche à rien pour finir c'est quand
même eu la grosse brute dans cette
histoire et il se comporte d'une manière
très choquant à ce conseil des ministres
convoqué comme ça un samedi j'avais un
en vedette américaine le coronavirus et
puis ensuite le clou du spectacle le
49-3 l'assemblée nationale ne pourra pas
discuter la gauche est prise de court
après un long conciliabule insoumis
communistes et socialistes finissent par
s'accorder sur une motion de censure
la droite a déjà déposé la sienne
il y en aura donc deux 48 heures ont
passé
nous arrivons à les pilotes de cette
bataille des retraites
à l'ordre du jour les motions de censure
et une manifestation devant l'assemblée
profitez de 2 dans ta vie rude où
passait le 49-3 vaut le faire tout le
temps ce droit là pour eux la colère
n'est toujours pas retombée
quelques députés communistes tentent de
remonter le moral des troupes
l'histoire est pas fini c'est pas parce
qu'il a sorti le 49-3 que
d'accord la manifestation se déroule
sous les fenêtres de catherine fabre et
monique limon les deux députés en marche
vous l'êtes améliorer certains points de
la réforme
mission accomplie à leurs yeux donc ça
c'est le texte qui sort de l'assemblée
nationale pour aller au sénat tous des
éléments qui sont en couleurs sont des
éléments que les parlementaires avec
leurs travaux ont contribué à faire
modifier
alors il n'a pas pu débattre mais au
moins on a pu les faire les mettre dans
le texte
il ya eu des amendements qui concerne
les droits familiaux pour les parents
isolés donc une majoration de points ça
n'existait pas dans le texte initial
pareil pour les parents d'enfants
porteurs de handicap où il ya des
préjudices de carrière quand même
important c'est le seul motif de
satisfaction pour les députés en marche
dans le texte soumis aux 49 3 le
gouvernement a retenu la plupart des
amendements de la majorité
pour le reste les deux députés garde un
goût amer de ce débat parlementaire
on est organisés d'une telle façon que
17 personnes nouveau vingtaine peuvent
empêcher 577 à travailler correctement
c'est grave moi je crois et comment on
peut dire on n'a pas réussi le 49-3
venez tous dans la revue on vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir et nous
pensaient en avoir pendant longtemps
sourds aux fenêtres de députés des
manifestants qui crient on est là mais
il y en a toujours eu
c'est un peu le général qui vient saluer
ses troupes après la bataille
sauf que pour jean luc mélenchon la
bataille n'est pas finie
c'est le message qu'il veut faire passer
aujourd'hui aussi bien à ses supporters
réunis devant l'assemblée que dans son
discours de motion de censure prononcée
dans la foulée il s'apprête à voter les
yeux fermés un texte qu'ils n'ont pas lu
pas discuter et quand ils ne connaissent
aucune des conséquences
vous allez accepter de laisser passer
sans débat un texte que vous n'avez
jamais lu
alors la bataille qui commence
maintenant est une bataille de longue
durée
nous n'en avons pas fini avec nous en
toute hypothèse est quoi qu'il arrive en
2022 nous avons ri femmes dès 2022 nous
annulerons tous comme j'avais fait la
promesse de jours meilleurs pour oublier
le présent car dans l'immédiat les
motions de censure sont rejetés
la majorité requise des temps pas
atteinte la motion de censure n'est pas
adoptée en conséquence est considéré
comme adopté le projet de loi instituant
un système universel de retraite la
réforme des retraites quitte ainsi
l'assemblée
en attendant la revanche et la deuxième
lecture du projet de loi
[Musique]